this is gonna work steve i know it is
because i don't know what i'm gonna do
if it doesn't
[Music]
hi uh is anyone home this is scott lang
we met a few years ago at the airport in
germany
i got really big is this an old message
ant-man
i know you don't i know you know that
it's the front door
that's me can you buzz me in
all right control's online
[Music]
the collection unit activates when you
decouple it it should automatically
start absorbing quantum healing
particles
also make sure you stay out of the
tardigrade fields they're cute but
they'll eat you
and don't get sucked into a time vortex
we won't be able to save you
okay going subatomic in five
four three
two one
hey everybody it's charlie so we got to
talk about that avengers 4
end game trailer in the ant-man scene
everybody has started to notice now
that there is archival footage so we
need to talk about how ant-man
is suddenly the most important character
in the mcu
and how his dirty old beat up funny
looking van is suddenly one of the most
important pieces of technology
in the universe there's a new brand of
that imax ticket giveaway to all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite moment from the
trailer on the video
charting the timeline in this clip you
have captain america and the other
surviving avengers sitting in the
avengers facility
talking about what they've lost trying
to figure out what to do next so he
shaved his beard so a little bit of time
has gone by
but not that much time because black
widow's hair is still blonde and very
short
so using their relative beard level and
hair level it seems like they didn't
spend too much time in wakanda after
the snapping they went back to the new
avengers facility they're regrouping and
looking through archival footage like
you have the scene
of bruce banner looking at all the
people they've lost i know there are a
lot of people wondering about shuri here
if it's one of the
false trailer moments like they're doing
a bit of a fake out to mislead you
because
a while ago the russos did say that
shuri was one of the people that
survived the snap
so because we know that they told a
bold-faced lie a little while ago also
talking about the
endgame title oh that's totally not the
title which of course
it actually is now i've seen some
conspiracy theories about that too
maybe the title is a fake out unless i
see some more compelling evidence i do
think that endgame is the real title but
yes there are probably a couple false
moments in this trailer
shuri is probably one of them but as
they're looking through all this footage
somehow this clip gets cued from the
front gate maybe the system
recognizes scott lang as one of the
avengers you don't really know how tony
stark's database works because even
though
he might be stuck in outer space all of
his technology is still operating like
it normally should
there's not a whole lot else in this
frame that tells you when this is
happening when ant-man pulls up
because you see the 1983 date it just
says strat 1983
archive in the upper left-hand corner
but you look at the front gate and it
looks kind of overgrown like it's
unkempt
people haven't been visiting it that
often there's a big sign
on the front of the gate and we actually
do have a couple shots of the avengers
base in the trailer and we saw them
drive through the front gate during
spider-man homecoming and it looks
way nicer so this obviously seems like
it's happening during a different time
period
probably during 1983 but that's where
you get to that ant-man post-credits
scene janet van dyne just reminding him
don't fall into a time vortice we won't
be able to save you she makes it sound
like they're very unpredictable
so a lot of people are just taking this
to be confirmation that they're paying
off that time vortices comment and he
accidentally time travels and jumps
around till he finally winds up in this
scene here
but even though it might be confirmation
of ant-man time traveling using quantum
energy in the quantum realm
he's not a genius so this is something
that he'd have to be doing on accident
he'd have to fall into one of the time
vortices and then
find someone who was smart enough to
understand how his quantum gear works
and then enable him to go back in time
because him falling into a time vorticy
doesn't explain how the van
travels in time with him because this is
definitely his van it probably has that
quantum tunnel in the back of it but
that's not exactly how time travel works
like if he fell into a time vorticy
inside the quantum realm then how would
the van outside of the quantum realm
also travel back with him that would
just be really weird
so the most logical way to explain this
like adding another layer of crazy
is that him in this clip here is not the
first time that he's traveled through
time using the quantum realm
what would have to happen is is that he
escapes the quantum realm at the
beginning of avengers 4 and accidentally
winds up in the future so that the van
is still there when he gets out of the
quantum realm
he finds everything is very different
but he's able to track down
an older version of cassie lang his
daughter and other avengers
science bros who are smart enough to
help him figure out what's going on
catch him up to speed on what thanos did
and help reconfigure his technology
because it's further in the future so
maybe they'll have more advanced science
that's more capable of fine-tuning the
quantum energy gear
so he goes back in time to try and warn
the avengers
but because it's still imprecise he
accidentally overshoots the mark and
winds up back in 1983
so that would mean that he'd also have
to time travel again to get back to
present day
probably with the help of other avengers
along the way there were rumors that
john slattery's howard stark was spotted
on the set of avengers 4
in 1983 howard stark was still very much
alive
so he could go seek him out thinking
that he was trying to find somebody
related to iron man you're smart you can
help me figure this stuff out
early theory maybe that has something to
do with it because he's just not smart
enough to figure this stuff out
all by himself he's not a scientist he's
a thief but if you're wondering there
are smart people in the mcu that are
alive in 1983 so there are people that
could help him like nick fury would
still be alive
what does that mean for the actual plot
of avengers 4 though like i said
ant-man's van if it can travel through
time with him is suddenly the most
important piece of technology in the
entire universe
because the only other way to do that is
to use the time stone and thanos still
has the charred infinity gauntlet in
what seems like a couple years after the
events of the snap so like he's on his
farm the gauntlet is still broken but
he's still got it here i know he's
walking through the field with it on
he probably takes it off at some point
but there have been a lot of rumors
about footage that they're cutting
in how like thanos will realize what
they're doing if they're traveling
through time
messing with things if he starts seeing
gems disappear
at random from the gauntlet like if he
were standing in his field here on titan
ii just enjoying life happy with himself
and all of a sudden he noticed one of
the infinity gems just winked out of
existence
he would probably instantly realize what
the avengers are doing
they're using time travel to try and
alter what i did
so early timeline of the movie you see
tony stark
running out of power in the guardianship
with nebula because remember they were
stuck on titan but the guardianship was
there so he's obviously using it to try
and get back home
this is where they're coming from this
is where planet earth is like i said
captain marvel
is probably in crete and scroll space in
the 20-year period that she's missing so
she's probably the closest person nearby
that can help pick them up on the way
home or rescue them if she gets a
distress signal even the people at nasa
are trying to get in on the fun the nasa
twitter account was talking about
pointing all of our communications
energy towards deep space to try and
pick up his distress signal
we've never really dealt with energy
reserves issues in the marvel universe
typically when ships travel from one
point to another in outer space they
travel through a wormhole and it seems
like a jump cut series like a really
short funny scene that just looks really
cool
and it seems like it happens almost
instantaneously the only reason why iron
man and nebula would be stuck in outer
space is if the parts that helped them
travel through those wormholes were
broken and they didn't have anything to
fix them with even iron man's technology
his nanobots weren't enough to fix that
because he says that he's run out of
food i'm guessing that this is a manner
of weeks
maybe not quite months after the end of
the snap
captain america with no beard black
widow with the really short hair also a
matter of months
after the snap them standing here on the
back where they're talking about whether
or not the plan is actually going to
work she still has
really short hair so this is probably
relatively soon after they find out
what's going on with ant-man
thor sitting here just sulking to
himself also probably pretty early in
the movie
if you're just talking about when these
scenes happen during the actual movie
i think that most of this footage from
the trailer is from the first 20 minutes
like we've seen footage
from behind the scenes with black widow
with really long red and blonde hair so
like her roots are just growing back out
because she has naturally red hair but
that would take a while to happen so you
just have to assume that all the footage
we see of her
and probably most of these other people
happen relatively early in the film
before any really big time jumps or
before they jump around in time a whole
bunch
the other thing you have to remember too
is this is all part of doctor strange's
one chance in 14 million that he saw
that them winning and the russos did
address that people asked him straight
up how come doctor strange didn't
mention anything about what they should
do
or what might happen but the real reason
is probably because
telling someone how to do things and
what their future is going to be
usually winds up leading to some
different outcome that doctor strange
would
not want so everybody post your time
travel theories in the comments below
what do you think the timeline is for
ant-man during the movie
what'll happen is there'll be more
marvel stuff happening next week they
still have to drop that spider-man far
from home trailer and there's going to
be more trailers from other people
coming before the end of the year leave
your requests in the comments below
congratulations oscar does stuff you're
the giveaway winner for my last big
marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so i can get
your contact details
click here to re-watch the avengers end
game trailer a billion more times
and click here for my breakdown of the
spider-man far from home trailer in the
big comic-con panel that they just did
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome see you guys tonight
[Music]
you